i like to see the people that buy
tickets to see me i like to touch them
and squeeze them and
[Music]
the last special was can i touch it and
then the pandemic happened and no one
could touch anyone
everyone better let me touch them on
this tour i have to
do justice to all the people that send
me these like gifts and letters and
stuff that was so touching
to me i think it'll be touching if i
have a shirt for every city i go to
it's a dress with the solar system on it
that'd be good for houston because it's
near nasa we're in atlantic city they
dress up
no because i'm actually a cougar now so
this isn't funny i
am 38 and i do need to conceive a child
soon
so i'm gonna have to bring some like
sexy lingerie on the road
my lover is a rock climber this i think
will make him want to touch me
climb these boulders big boy
this is sexy it feels like an armadillo
this will not make him want to touch me
oh and it's got a hairy butt this is my
vision board
for when i must have been 22
royal oak music theater royal oak
music theater if that doesn't make you
a little emotional that's not a little
touching you're a psychopath
i'm gonna touch your heart i'm gonna
touch your brain
and i'm gonna make you laugh so hard
that you gotta
touch your privates to stop from peeing
i'm doing venues that are on my vision
board shut up